واختتموا اليوم مواجهته دور السته عشر
لبطوله كاس العالم في قطر بمباراتين حيث
يخوض المغرب وبعد تاهله التاريخي واحتلاله
صداره المجموعه السادسه يخوض ليلا امتحان
صعبا امام منتخب اسبانيا في
مطعم البرتغال مباراه صعبه امام منتخب
سويسرا على ان يتواجه الفائزين في هاتين
المبارتين في دور الثمانيه
يسعى المنتخب المغربي لكتابه تاريخ جديد
خلال مشاركته السادسه في نهائيات كاس
العالم عندما يلتقي المنتخب الاسباني بطل
مونديال 2010 هذه الليله ويدافع منتخب
المغرب عن الحظوظ العربيه بعد النبات
الممثل الوحيد المتبقي في منافسات
المونديال
وعلى استاد المدينه التعليميه في الدوحه
يتطلع اسود الاطلس لتكرار انجازهم عام 86
عندما كانوا اول منتخب عربي وافريقيا يبلغ
ثمن نهائي العرس العالمي قبل ان يخرجوا
على يد المانيا الغربيه حينها بهدف في
اللحظات الاخيره هذه المره يطمح المنتخب
المغربي الى تحقيق ما فشل فيه الجيل
الذهبي بقياده محمد التيمومي والعزيز
بودرباله والى كتابه تاريخ جديد ببلوغ دور
ربع النهائي للمره الاولى وتكرار انجاز
الكاميرون والسنغال وغاما
90 و2000 و 2010 تواليا وقد افتتح منتخب
اسود الاطلس بقياده المدرب وليد الركراك
مشواره في المجموعه بالتعادل من دون اهداف
مع منتخب كرواتيا وصيف المونديال الماضي
قبل ان يحقق انتصارا تاريخيا بهدفين
نظيفين على بلجيكا المصنفه ثانيا عالميا
قبل تاكيد جدارته بالفوز بهدفين مقابل هد
وحيد على كندا وقد اكد الركراكي ان منتخب
المغرب سيدخل المواجهه مع اسبانيا من دون
اي ضغوط ومن اجل اقتناص ورقه الترشح لدور
الثمانيه رغم اعترافه بصعوبه المواجهه حيث
يمتلك المنتخب الاسباني قدرات عاليه على
المستويين الفردي والجماعي وهو قادر على
امتلاك الكره بشكل كبير
وقال ركراكه الذي اصبح اول مدرب محلي يخوض
احد المنتخبات العربيه لبلوغ الادوار
الاقصائيه بكاس العالم قال ان اسود الاطلس
سيخوضون المواجهات دون اي عقد مضيفا ان
المغرب عازمزم على بلوغ دور الثمانيه
على كل المزيد من الدوحه معي بالمزيد من
المتابعه من الدوحه موفد العربيه ليث
بازاري ومن الرباط ينضم اليه مراسل
العربيه عادل الزبير ابدا معك ليث كيف هي
الاجواء من عندك واخر التوقعات لموقعات
المغرب اسبانيا الليل
للفوز في هذه المباراه التي ستقام بعد اقل
من ساعه من خلفي في استاد المدينه
التعليميه ايديكيشن سيتي وهنا شباب مغاربه
يعني اليوم الدوحه احمر واخضر من الصباح
حتى هذه الساعه قبل المباراه
شو عندكم كمان هدى
ماشي مغربي
حضرتك من وين هذا مين فاز من هذا المغرب
من مدينه فاس انا نقاط هنا
وانا عايشه
من المغرب
لفتتني شغله قبل شوي هناك شاب مغربي اتى
على دراجه تخيل على دراجه هوائيه
للوصول الى هنان تشجيع المنتخب المغربي
هذه الدراجه
الشاب طبعا هذه امور المباشر معنا هذه
الدراجه وهو ذهب ينتقد صور امام الملعب
تخيل انه شحن دراجته من المغرب كازابلانكا
من الدار البيضاء الى اسطنبول ومن ثم على
متني
هذه الدراجه انتقل اسطنبول الى هنا هذا
الشاب وصل
عليكم السلام شو اسمك السلام عليكم اسمي
صلاح الدين بن نارين
بتيجي على دراجه كانت صعب الرحله ولا لا
همم صراحه رحله كان صعبه يعني كما قلت لك
كما اقول لك انطلقش من تركيا وبالضبط من
اسطنبول وتوجهت نحو الاردن والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه والان انا في تونس قطر
الخير وبعد قطر ان شاء الله يعني هناك
رحله الى مكه
افريقيا او امشي نحو اسيا بس انت خططت
لتكون مش بالمونديال بهذه الفتره توصل هنا
الى الدوحه ولا جاءت الصدف انك وصلت وقت
الموضوع يعني انا ضليت سنه ونصف وانا احضر
لهذه الرحله يعني
في التاريخ لا هي كانت
مخطط لها همم مره يسمن همم عديمه تجارب
لكي اكون جاهز في هذه الرحله كان هناك
تحضير بدني تحضير جسدي تحضير مادي والحمد
لله بعد كل هذه المسير انا هنا في قطر نعم
اذا شاهدنا الدراجه طالب اذا سمعت هذه
دراجه الشعب كما نشاهد يحمل اشياء قليل لا
يوجد الكثير من امتعه مع مع الدراجه التي
هل كانت هذه ما تحمل هنا كافيا الوصول هنا
الى الماضيه نعم همم
الاوزان يسمى تقريبا البيك باكين هو يعني
هنا بين
حاولت ان اقود همم اخذ همم
يعني
ههه
عن جد رحله فظيعه ولكن اذا تشاهدنا حامل
انت تذكره معك بطاقه لحضور المباراه بين
المغرب واسبانيا بعد قليل يعني الشهر عند
الشاب طالب يقدر يوصل هل اشتريت التذاكر
هل اشتريت هذه التذكره قبل ما تاتي او
تخطط همم لا تخطط لا لانك صار لك سنه ونصف
بتخططها ما اشتريت هذه التذكره
همم الثلاثه الاولى ولما همم يعني اخذ مر
الى الدور ثمن نهائي حصلت على هذا التذكره
التذكره عندي سؤال فطوري وراح يكون الاخير
هلا لما بدك تفوت على الملعب تحضر
المباراه شو راح تعمل بهالدرجه ثمينه لا
انت بدونها ما بتقدر تتنقل همم صراحه لما
افوت امشي اودعها هنا في مكان همم
الدراجات الان يعني قطر دوله امنه يعني
نزل دراجتك حتى ولو تمسكها مع اي مكان
يعني ولا هذه يقرب يعني الحمد لله السؤال
الاخير شو اكثر صعوبه واجهتك بالرحله من
اسطنبول الى هنا
لكن كان صعوبه يعني انا لما عرفت نفسي
انني وصلت بمرض همم الاكزيما هو مرض زفاف
اليدين
التي سامع خبر انه صعب انه يعني همم
برده نفسانيا كثير لاني كنت عارف بانني
سوف امر من اصعب التجارب في الطريق شكرا
طيب لايف همم
سعيد المغربي
كل التمنيات بالتوفيق بطبيعه الحال
للمنتخب المغربي الليله الجماهير العربيه
همم في الدوحه كلها المغرب الليله تشجيع
كله للمغرب الجماهير ولكن الى اي ماده
سيكون لمنتخب اسبانيا مشجعين داخل الملعب
قياسا بال- بالمشجعين بالمغاربه همم خصوصا
والمشجعين العرب عموما
سؤال كتير
ولكن شاهدت كثير ما ننسى انه هذا الفوز
ليس فقط العرب الافارقه هم جزء من هذا
الفوز لا يوجد منتخبات افريقيه الان
والمغرب تقع في القاره الافريقيه اذان
النجاح راح يكون دبل النجاح عربي اذا فاز
المغرب في هذه المباراه هنا في المدينه
التعليميه وسيكون ايضا النجاح افريقي كذلك
واذا شاهدنا اخذنا الكاميرا ما بعرف ادعي
لنا لواء الطالب الجماهير ما زال تتواجد
المباراه بعد 45 دقيقه من الان ولكن
الحشود الحشود طيب همم الشباب
همم
كفتات شكرا لك لايت مزاري كنت معنا من همم
الدوحه بالطبع اللي انا عوده اليك في سياق
النشرات المتابعه نتيجه هذه المباراه
الان همم مراسل العربيه من الرباط عادل
الزبير انضم الينا عادل اهلا وسهلا بك مع
تمنياتنا بطبيعه الحال بفوز المنتخب
المغربي هذه الليله كيف يتابع اهل المغرب
هذا الحدث الليله وهل ستكون المهمه الصعبه
ام سهله برايهم
مرحبا طالب الجماهير المغربيه الان تفكر
بقلبها وبعواطفها وتريد انتصارا تاريخيا
مغربيا باسم المغاربه والعرب والافارقه
تريد انجازا تاريخيا جديدا من اسود الاطلس
ببلوغ الربع لاول مره في تاريخ هذا
المنتخب المغربي يتوفر بحسب النقاد
الرياضيين وبحسب الشارع الرياضي المغربي
همم على منتخب تاريخ استثناء بامكانه
صناعه المزيد من افراح المغاربه المغاربه
الان تتوقف حياتهم جميعا من اجل ان
يتحولوا الى تتبع المباراه والتشجيع
المقاهي المطاعم الساحات كل الاماكن
الممكن ان تتحول الى اماكن الفرجه
المغاربه تجمع فيها هنا من خلف هذا المقهى
يعني اصبح مقتضا بالجماهير نساء ورجال
الشباب الكل يريد اليوم ان ياتي لمنتخب
المغرب طبعا المباراه صعبه وصعبه جدا
لمنتخب اسبانيا بطل العالم في جنوب
افريقيا 2010 ديه نجوم كبار لكن
الضعف المنتخب الاسباني هي حارس المرمى
وهي خط الدفاع طبعا الجمهور المغربي هنا
في الرباط يقول اذا لعب وليد الركراكي
بخطه مباراه بلجيكا سوف يفوز المغرب واذا
فتح المباراه وهدم يريد المنتخب الاسباني
ستكون المهمه صعبه طيب همم نعادل في حال
الفوز وهذا همم ما نتمناه ويتمناه كل
العرب الليله المنتخب المغربي في حال
الفوز هل تم تحضيرات معينه لفعاليات همم
احتفاليه في الرباط وفي المدن المغربيه
املا القيمون على ذلك لا يتحدثون بهذه
المساله يتركونها مفاجاه
الطالب ااا الاعراف المغربيه او التقاليد
المغربيه في تشجيع المنتخب المغربي هو
خروج جماعي عفوي طبيعي للمغاربه الى
الساحات الملتقيات الشوارع قلب العاصمه
وفي كل المدن يخرجون بشكل جماعي وعفو
ويعودون حتى ان ما تسمى في كره القدم
بالفانزول او مناطق المشجعين لا توجد الا
منطقه واحده قامت بها احد الشركات
التجاريه المغربيه في مدينه كازابلانكا
الدار البيضاء باقي المغارب يشجعون في
المنازل في المقاهي في المطاعم هنالك نوع
من التلقائيه طبعا ما بعد ربع النهائي
ستكون هنالك كلمه اخرى ومن الممكن ان تكون
هنالك فعاليات لكن كما شاهدنا لما تاهل
المنتخب المغربي المغاربه خرجوا بمئات
الالاف في كل المدن خرجوا بطريقه عفويه
تلقائيه هدفه شجعوا وتحمس وغادروا هنا في
هذه المقهى من خلفي الناس يخرجون الى اقرب
نقطه للتشجيع والتعبير عن حماسيه ثم
يعودون الى بيوتهم ممتاز ما الرباط مراسل
العربيه عادل الزبير شكرا جزيلا لك يا
عادل وتمنياتنا بطبيعه حاب التوفيق
للمنتخبات المغربيه هذه الليله